welcome back I hope you've got your
coffee I see somebody has a muffin
they'll be in a carb coma Frances I'm
relying on you answer all the hard hard
questions
that's not authorized all right
so multi engine and Jets the piston twin
the good news is when both engines are
spinning it's easier to fly than a
single because you don't need as much
right rudder or really any right rudder
it doesn't have all those left-turning
tendencies necessarily the training and
rating especially the seminole which has
counter rotating props all your training
for a multi-engine airplane is flying
around on one engine because flying
around on two engines is pretty much the
same so basically almost all the flight
time that you accumulate during your
multi-engine training will be with one
engine pulled back to idle or in some
cases stopped altogether you have six
power lovers in a twin-engine piston
airplane to four throttle to four
mixture and to four prop you may also
have cowl flaps to bring more or less
cooling air into these piston engines
there is by FAA certification
requirements as I think I mentioned
earlier there's no required climb rate
it may be a truly crummy airplane on one
engine so that's why people say you know
that second engine either takes you to
the scene of the accident one engine
expert Mike Bush he said you know he
came to appreciate the cirrus parachute
it's not like having that extra engine
out there on the wing trying to kill you
all the time it just waits there quietly
until you need it
piston twins have an illustrious history
here's a Aero commander piston driven
twin that was actually Eisenhower's Air
Force One this also tells you something
about the growth of government when
Eisenhower was president and wanted to
go to a smaller Airport this is how he
would go in an airplane
designed for about six people okay this
is probably what you'll be flying which
is the piper Seminole it is unusual in
that the props counter rotate and that
has some advantages that are beyond the
scope of this talk it's a design from
the 70s based on designs from the 50s
where the problems happen so have a look
here
can anybody immediately see what one
problem might be let's say the left
engine quits and you have to manipulate
these what happens okay you know the
controls for the the good engine instead
of for the failed engine unit written
like so it's just an interface that's
overly complex given human frailties so
what do you have to do if an engine
quits you don't want the drag of that
propeller out there that's not being
driven by the engine so you push all the
levers forward to try to get maximum
power out of your good engine push
everything forward you'll have to put in
some rudder to correct the yaw because
the airplane is going to be pulled to
one side of the other depending on which
engine is still running and then there's
the there's the old adage dead foot dead
engine so if your left foot is flat on
the floor and it's your right rudder
that's in then you know that it's the
left engine that has failed then you try
to verify the dead engine by pulling
back that throttle so you'll say okay I
think the left engines failed I'm gonna
try monkeying with the left throttle and
if that has no effect on the flight
characteristics you verify that it's the
left engine
then you feather the dead engine by
pulling the prop control all the way
back if you're within a two pilot crew
you'll get your copilot to verify I have
and on the Left prop control and you
pull that back
close the Cal Cal flaps and only now do
you have any chance of getting actual
climb so imagine if this engine fails
shortly after takeoff it's a lot of
stuff to do very quickly if you have to
do it all right and if you miss even one
of these things you may not be able to
clear obstacles at the end of the runway
now of course you know your typical
piston twin takeoff is a stressful time
for an engine 100 percent power but
there's definitely more engine failures
that occur enroute so the generally
negative impression of piston twins
might have to be revised if you're a
primary mission is flying around the
Caribbean islands you might in that case
actually say well I'd rather have that
second engine is this within human
capability that sequence that you just
saw yes in World War two when engines
weren't being made with as much
precision as they are now you know it
would be ordinary to have one out of
four engines or one out of two engines
fail on any given mission but they also
got it wrong there's one very famous guy
Louie Zamperini some of you may have
seen a movie about him he floated in a
raft for 47 days I think that was a
record at the time for survival at sea
he was on a four-engined aircraft and
one engineer quit and I think there were
about four pilots in the cockpit
remember we talked about a flight
engineer also being an air man so if we
count the flight engineer as a pilot
there were at least three or four
experts up front and as a team they
feathered the wrong engine so they
killed a second engine it was actually
good and now they had two engines
working on only one side of the airplane
and it was uncontrollable
so they went in the water through human
error and
Cape air has a great retract record
they've had a handful of engine failures
over the years they fly piston twins all
day every day in the Caribbean and
around New England and when they have a
problem usually it's not a complete
failure but maybe there's an ugly
indication on one engine
so they'll shut it down but they do a
lot of recurrent training that's what
they fly all day every day
the typical family airplane doesn't get
flown as often and the pilot is in this
Perficient so the capable twins are very
inexpensive now except for the
Beechcraft Baron which is kind of the
most sought-after
they're a little more expensive to
insure and the comparable signal a
single just the other day I got a quote
from a local insurance agency called
plane insurance and we found out that if
you look at a $200,000 aircraft being
flown by a pilot that has 250 hours of
experience in type in that exact
aircraft and with a million dollars of
smooth liability that means no sub
limits so if there's just one passenger
they would pay out all million dollars
for injuries to that one passenger some
policies have like $100,000 per person
supplement anyway it was about 50% more
for the Baron $3,700 a year versus
$2,500 there you have it
again you know it's not insanely risky
you can quantify the risk the insurance
company has but it is riskier okay we
have a lot of engineering geniuses in
this class and one physics genius
science which one was it that's close
enough to physics
brain incog takes a lot of physics to
make your neurons fire obviously my
neurons on firing very well so what is
what's the limit to a piston engines
power like why is it that we can't get
you know six thousand horsepower out of
our piston engine what do you guys think
cooling is one sure what else like
what's fundamentally limiting our
ability to produce power remember all
the power that we produce is by burning
fuel and oxygen yeah I think you know
that's a good insight it's the size of
the cylinder you only have so much fuel
and air that you can combust and once
you've flown all that up what do you got
nothing so if you want to know why you
should never be like the Silicon Valley
heroes and never hire anybody over the
age of 30 the inventor of the modern jet
engine was only 23 years old I believe
at the time that the patent was filed
over in England he was a cadet when he
conceived the idea at the Royal Air
College and he said well look these
Pistons you know no matter how high up
you go no matter what you do all you can
ever do is burn the volume of air and
fuel that's inside the cylinder so what
if we just have this adapt this gas
turbine which has already been invented
it was kind of invented in 1791 but not
really practical to fabricate at the
time but look we're just sucking in all
this air we can probably get 20 times as
much air in if we just vacuumed it in
and suck it into a turbine and then
light it on fire so that was the idea
the fundamental insight for why a gas
turbine is going to be a better machine
for propelling aircraft
he struggled with funding so you can see
the patent was filed in 1930 and it was
only until nineteen it was only a 1941
that it finally got flown and that's a
good lesson for you entrepreneurs a lot
of MIT startups have the characteristic
that they're a bit too early I remember
I built in 1994 I built the world's
first electronic medical record system
that had a web interface so that had
zero value at the time and you know but
10 years later it was a multi-billion
dollar idea
so yeah Whittle died in relative
obscurity in 1996 so nobody else liked
this idea at the time I'll let you read
that quote not totally wrong of course
because it did take quite a bit of
Engineering to make it truly practical
but that didn't take as long as people
thought all right
you saw this figure before this is the
modern turbojet or turbofan engine where
you have this bypass air so that's this
the top of the duct is devoted to or the
outer outer ring is devoted to air that
really never goes through and gets
burned by the in the power section and
that provides a lot of additional
propulsion for not a whole lot of extra
energy so these are much more efficient
than the early pure turbojet so just to
remind you you have the compressor
section where you have air being
squeezed
now you introduce some fuel catches on
fire from the extreme heat or the
igniters if you're just starting up that
drives these power turbines and some of
the spinning from the power turbines
goes back to spin the compressor wheels
as well as the fan in front which is
kind of like the propeller
all right what about having two turbojet
engines a lot of people like to see two
engines on their aircraft especially
airline passengers if you have an engine
failure what do you do the answer is
pretty much nothing
maybe you if it hasn't been done
automatically for you already you can
advance the thrust levers if the
airplane is yawning that sometimes is
automatically corrected for you but to a
substantial extent by the yaw damper you
will step on a rudder to do the natural
thing and bring the nose back pointed to
where you want it pointed and it'll keep
climbing nicely you've arranged
everything both in terms of the design
of the aircraft and the weight at which
you took off so that no matter the
environmental conditions you will be
able to climb and you will be able to
clear the obstacles this can be a
challenge if you're taking off out of a
mountainous high-altitude hot Airport
you're not going to have a full load of
fuel and a full load of people and bags
but by regulation you're gonna be able
to clear the terrains if safely even on
one engine why is it so much easier you
don't have a propeller that'll drag back
a wing and therefore there's no urgency
about feathering you also have a little
bit less of the crazy off because the
engines are and some aircraft pretty
close to the fuselage so basically you
can still apply that cardinal rule of
flying jets if the switch has dust on it
don't touch it so you don't have to be
take immediate action all right if it's
turbojet-powered though you do need
specific training and you have to pass
the check ride specific to that aircraft
so most of you guys except for Francis
believe that captain Sully was all by
himself in the a320 but actually
anything that's more than about a ten
seater almost always requires two pilots
and the types are according to the type
certificate it's not even legal to
operate you know even the larger
business jets with one pilot there is
there is an old far 91.5 I believe that
says there has to be a proficiency check
annually for the pilot in command of a
to pilot aircraft and more recently the
regulations were updated for a single
pilot turbo jets so that a checkride has
to be done annually which is not really
that different from the insurance
requirements of annual training they
just made it a little more formalized
with FA bureaucracy
all right turbojet you might own the
single pilot business jet with kind of a
straight wing they said initially the
Cessna Citation was so slow that birds
were hitting it from behind but you know
sometimes safety and being having it be
easy to operate by people of ordinary
skill and people of lower skill levels
is better than getting that last 50
knots of speed and that's what Cessna
figured out so there's still kind of a
leader in this area they produce the
Cessna Mustang which you see there at
the right there was a Microsoft some of
the Microsoft folks they spun off a
design called the Eclipse it was
supposed to have these new cruise
missile inspired engines from Williams
they never wrote the engines didn't work
so the 1500 nautical mile airplane
became you know a 900 nautical mile
airplane with a pratt & whitney more
conventional design engine that's used
on some of these other designs the
embraer phenom 100 has the same engines
essentially as the Mustang same family
Honda jet has an innovative engine
designed by GE and Honda these have all
pretty much been business failures and
the answer to that is the fixed costs of
jet ownership are so high you need to
pay you can't just you know get a tea
hangar for $800 a month you may have to
pay at one of the busier airports
you know $40,000 a year to have an FBO
hangar it for you
the insurance company will require
simulator training annually and you'll
probably have to have two pilots
as a practical matter go through
training insurance will be expensive
because the whole value is high you know
if you wrecked a five million dollar
airplane or a ten million dollar
airplane that's a bad day for the
insurance company you get charged a lot
more for landing fees and parking at
airports you know when you're a little
Cessna they kind of give you a break
because they don't want you saying
anything bad about them on air navcom
but if you show up in a Gulfstream they
figure you probably have a credit card
somewhere
so yeah the Mustang they actually
stopped production of that plane the
phenom 100 is still going from Embraer
but basically I think the phenom 300 is
holds about nine or ten people and I
think it weighs somewhere in the 15,000
to 20,000 pound range those are the at
gross those are the airplanes that seem
to be popular phenom 300 is about nine
million dollars new and three to five
million used applies including the
things like the Cessna cj3 a three
million dollar plane could be a cj3 all
right what about single-engine jets the
problem is they're more vulnerable to
engine failure jet engines are a little
bit more vulnerable to failure from say
a bird strike or something and a piston
engine and therefore you need some way
of dealing with the consequence of
having that engine fail the cirrus jet
is pretty slow so it could actually be
landed off the airport perhaps without
too much damage but it has a parachute
in case and f-16 and other fighter jets
that are single-engine they obviously
have ejection seats twin turbo props
let's talk about those so if you want to
land on a short runway we talked about
turboprop engines I think on day one
they can produce a tremendous amount of
power so you can have a much bigger
heavier airplane but because they're
driving a propeller you get to take off
and land short they develop thrust very
effectively at low speeds
and the prop is a huge drag so when you
land it kind of slows down and stops
immediately or almost immediately so the
the king air from 1964 to the present
with these Pratt & Whitney engines that
were developed in the very end of the
50s the PT six those have been hugely
popular when you hit a bird it's a
problem for the bird but not usually for
the propeller the King airs and this ATR
they have an auto feather system if one
engine loses power the propeller will
automatically go to this knife-edge
configuration I should have said what
feathering is you twist the propeller
blades so that they're edge to the wind
instead of flat to the wind so you
dramatically reduce the drag of the
propeller so that airplane actually kind
of took care of itself or should have
taken care of itself pretty well you can
read about that crash I think it was in
Taiwan but the pilots decided to take
heroic immediate action or at least one
of the pilots did and shut down the good
engine instead of just leaving well
enough alone okay single-engine
turboprop says these engines got more
refined and more reliable if you look at
the PT six design it has all kinds of
tubes and hoses and vacuum going from
one place to another bleed air you'd be
surprised that it's as reliable as it is
but they supposedly don't really have to
be shut down for a problem or fail more
than about once every three four or five
hundred thousand hours so after that
insight people said let's let's just put
one of them in and we don't need that
second engine it'll save a ton of money
so the so the Cessna Caravan is a great
example of that that's a that sort of
boxy cargo plane that you saw on floats
in the other video for personal
airplanes that are pressurized and more
comfortable the piper meridian which is
figured which is down here this is
my friend Arnold who's at Hanscom he
says he he funded his airplanes because
he was practicing during the Golden Age
of gynecology and that's what enabled
him to afford his fancy pressurized
pipers the TBM is a French design that's
considerably preferred to the piper but
it's a lot more expensive and then the
Swiss Pilatus pc-12 is kind of a good
airplane for a mixture of family use and
charter use the piper and the TBM are
kind of too small to justify all the
machinery around charter alright so
actually old King airs are cheaper than
these single-engine airplanes but they
cost a little more to run all right when
you're maintaining a jet I think I
mentioned this earlier the manufacturers
guidance will supersede those capsule
rules of a 100 hour inspection for an
airplane operated annually operated
commercially or the annual inspection
for an airplane operated privately it
can get expensive on you know one of
those Cessna Citation Jets that I
mentioned coming out with a hundred
thousand dollar bill from the annual
would not be unexpected you usually have
a time limit on the whole airframe
because and if it's pressurized it's
getting expanded and contracted expanded
and contracted and a little bit of metal
fatigue on every flight so you may have
a limit on the number of cycles the
number of times that's happened and also
on the number of hours so a 12,000 hour
or 20,000 hour airframe life limit might
be common for the Pallotta PSA's it's
20,000 hours and then they have life
extension program so they tear the whole
thing apart and replace some structures
or at least look at every structure
people have extended them out to about
32,000 hours I think now cycle limits
also on the jet engines so the turbine
blades and stuff and discs every time
they're started and shut down there's a
huge amount of thermal cycling so they
say look after you've done that you know
15 thousand times you got to throw that
and that wheel inside the turboprop
could be $100,000 if you guys ever you
know it may seem hard to believe now
that mit has stripped you of all of your
savings but if you do have a little bit
of money at some future date and you
want to get a type rating for an
airplane by far the cheapest type rating
you get will be for a big airplane so it
turns out if you want to pay flight
safety for a Gulfstream rating or a
Cessna Mustang rating or whatever those
are pretty expensive they're relatively
rare Boeing 737s and Airbus a320s so
many were made that there's a just a
wide variety of simulators all over the
world and for about ten thousand dollars
you can jump in and get your instrument
proficiency back up to snuff as well as
some well as have a lot of fun alright
so as a summary it's a good challenge to
get that multi-engine rating
I wouldn't recommend sort of practicing
it unless you have an unusual
application like you live in the
Caribbean and you want to get from
island to island if you're nervous and
somebody says you know I don't feel
comfortable depending on this
five-year-old thousand hour just an
engine that's in front of us the answer
I think these days is it's better to get
an airplane that has a ballistic
parachute as your backup and to have the
second engine as a backup and while
you're formulating your questions I'll
show you on the top left is a French
design that's called a cree-cree
it seats one person and it's I believe
fully aerobatic so you can do all kinds
of crazy maneuvers and the Cree Cree if
you want each of those engines might be
only 30 horsepower 15 you can look it up
at some cut it's a truly crazy design
here is an AirCam that's an open cockpit
although this one has a canopy that's
from the Oshkosh seaplane base a great
airplane for flying low and slow over
remote somewhat wet locations here's an
l-39 Czech military trainer
and there's a company called I think it
was called code one aviation they had
that at Oshkosh where they took in a
regular American business jet engine out
of a Hawker and they stuffed it into the
l-39 because it's cheaper to operate and
maintain and as lower fuel burn and the
military engine so you end up getting a
lot longer range out of your l-39 if you
want to those l-39s are only a couple
hundred thousand dollars for a nice one
so you can actually own a jet that's
fully aerobatic and cool and look like
people will think it's an f-16 for less
money than buying a Cirrus on the left
is the ramp at Teterboro I said I was
talking about if you want to start a if
you're working for Bernie Sanders and
you want to start a revolution in the US
I would recommend starting it right at
the Teterboro Airport and just film the
people getting in out of there
Gulfstream's and this is Meridian this
is the lowest-cost FBO at Teterboro and
that's the what the ramp looks like if
you want to combine two piston engines
in a jet I believe each of these there's
each of these is a yak 55 and some
airshow performer at Oshkosh glued them
together and put a jet engine in the
middle and calls it a yak 110 so there
you have it that combines everything
from this talk any questions or should
we jump right into Knight who wants to
fly a jet excellent
so Gary Anderson I really tried as a
person
yeah the question is you know is it okay
to fly a single-engine overwater in
Hawaii and assessing the caravan with
only one engine and if you well first of
all very the the last crash of a caravan
in Hawaii from an engine field they
operated it just like a few hours beyond
the manufacturers t-bo under a sort of a
special program they had approved by the
FAA they were not doing anything illegal
everybody survived the crash
one person was killed does anybody
remember who was who was killed in that
crash and what's special what was
special about that person it was a it
was a woman who was a state state of
Hawaii employee what was special about
her she was the person who certified
Barack Obama's birth certificate as
genuine think about that so anyway if
you if you really if you open up the pt6
and the manual you would say no I'm not
going to allow this and I think in
Europe Europe wouldn't even laugh single
engine charter IFR until just a year or
two ago you know they said no this is
too much so I don't know it's it's a
balancing of risk I don't think it's an
unacceptable risk to I mean people with
potus's they will go back and forth to
Europe regularly as individuals but yeah
maybe there should be a warning to
passengers you only got one engine
thanks for buying a ticket
you